geschmacklich geschmacklich bin ich kein
Unterschied muss ich sagen
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es wieder was herzhaftes und
zwar muss ich einige Zuschauer von mir
mal wieder nachgemacht Rezepte gewünscht
Maggi oder Knorr oder andere fertig
Gerichte die es eben so gibt und für
heute habe ich mir gedacht machen wir
Hühnerfrikassee nach vielleicht noch
dazu diese Videos sind nicht gesprochen
hat denn ich glaube nicht dass man
möchte dass ich so Rezepte Nachmache
aber was soll's wir nehmen später
einfach diese Knorr Packung her und ich
werde die dann noch Packungsanleitung
zubereiten oder vielleicht kriege ich ja
auch den Murat oder so dazu jemanden der
das kocht und ich werde das ganze dann
klassisch zubereiten bei einem früh
Hühnerfrikassee ist es so dass man
normalerweise ein ganzes Huhn nimmt und
es schön kocht und gart und dann eben
daraus dieses leckere Gericht zubereitet
was später in einer leichten weißen Soße
zubereitet wird und es schmeckt echt
sehr sehr gut viele machen es aber
mittlerweile so und so ist auch die
Verpackung dass man eben nur noch eine
Hühnerbrust stimmt was ich tatsächlich
bisschen schade finde weil ich finde
wenn man schon Tiere ist dann könnte man
direkt das ganze
tierverwerten und das war eigentlich
immer Sinn und Sache dass man im ganzes
Huhn nimmt und wirklich alles verwertet
und da unter komplette Geschmack mit
reinkommt ihr könnt es natürlich so
machen wie er möchtet normalerweise ist
beim Hühnerfrikassee so dass es Fleisch
vorgegart wird und so werde ich es jetzt
auch machen aber wenn ihr sagt das ist
euch zu viel Arbeit ihr könnt auch zum
Beispiel wenn ihr mal so ein Grillhendl
hattet könnt ihr das noch mit verwerten
oder ein Hähnchen was ihr vielleicht
angebraten habt könnt es auch noch
zweckentfremden und einfach eine
Resteverwertung machen aber ihr könnt
auch hergehen und sagen ich nehme
einfach nur eine Hühnerbrust brat die an
und brat macht dann daraus die Soße ja
also ihr könnt wirklich so wie ihr das
möchtet ich habe jetzt nur gerade
Hähnchen da und dachte mir ich koche
jetzt wirklich die Brühe auch selber
ansonsten im Alltag muss ich sagen wenn
ich jetzt nicht gerade noch
Hähnchenschenkel mit Knochen und so
weiter hätte im Alltag würde ich jetzt
auch einfach die Hühnerbrust nehmen und
das Rezept zubereiten das heißt das
erste was ich machen werde ich nehme
hier die Hühnerbrust und auch das
Fleisch was eingefroren war ich hatte da
nämlich so ein bio-huhn und habe ein
ganzes gekauft und einfach alles
eingefroren gebe ich jetzt hier in
meinem Topf
gemeinsam mit der Hühnerbrust und die
hebe ich aber auf für die fix Packung ja
das machen wir dann schon so wie es da
auf dem Rezept steht Hände immer gut
waschen gerade bei Hähnchenfleisch muss
man da aufpassen das Waschbecken immer
schön desinfizieren und Schneidebrett
und so weiter ich gebe jetzt hier
nämlich einfach ein Lorbeerblatt dazu
oder zwei halbe bisschen Salz und
Pfeffer
damit es Fleisch einfach auch schon
schön an Aromen gewinnt
und meine selbstgemachte Gemüsebrühe da
findet ihr das Rezept bereits auf meinem
Kanal ansonsten könnt ihr auch hier
Gemüsebrühe einfach so dazugeben oder
auch das ganze einfach mit Kräutern
verfeinern
das Wasser aufgießen und etwa 15 Minuten
kochen
das Hähnchen kocht gerade und hier sind
die Zutaten die ich noch brauche eine
Zwiebel Champignons die habe ich
Karotten die sind bereits geschält
jeweils 25 Gramm Butter und Mehl für die
Mehlschwitze 150 g Erbsen die waren
gefroren ich habe ich ein Gefäß für die
Hühnerbrühe die ich gleich habe etwas
Sahne Zitrone Salz und Pfeffer ich werde
jetzt zuerst die Zwiebel einfach mal
fein hacken die karottenwürfel und die
Champignons in Scheiben schneiden oh das
mein Backofen
das Hähnchen ist jetzt fertig gegart
und ich habe jetzt hier meine
Gemüsebrühe das heißt ich nehme das
Hähnchen erstmal raus
und kann die Gemüsebrühe abwägen und den
Topf leer machen denn darin wird gleich
gekocht
wir sind jetzt bereit und Kochen jetzt
nebeneinander nicht gegeneinander denn
das ist nicht Juttas Rezept sondern ein
fertiges Rezept wie ich nur noch mal
betonen und Jutta bereitet es einfach
kurz nach Packungsanleitung zu damit wir
später blind verkosten können ich habe
jetzt hier meinen Topf meine Gemüse
nehme meine Hühnerbrühe ist abgekocht
jetzt mache ich eine Mehlschwitze das
bedeutet die Butter kommt jetzt in den
Topf
wird zerlassen und da kommt Mehl dazu
und es immer so die Grundlage für alle
helle Soßen
jetzt das ganze schön anschwitzen bis es
hellbraun ist
ich gebe jetzt hier noch die Zwiebeln
rein
und ich schneide dann hier schon mal das
Hähnchenfleisch klein
da gebe ich jetzt hier die Hühnerbrühe
dazu und immer schön rühren
[Musik]
dann gebe ich jetzt hier die
Gemüsewürfel dazu
und auch gern schon die Erbsen bisschen
Salz und Pfeffer also jetzt schön
abschmecken und das Hähnchen kommt aber
erst später da rein
das wird man nie erleben dass die Jutta
mal Magie kocht genauso wie bei mir
aber man muss halt sagen
ja und wenn man halt keine Zeit hat
meine Güte dann ist halt alles schon
vorgemischt
ist halt so
als ich beurteile keinen der
Fertiggerichte zubereitet weil ich finde
sowas gekocht ist immer noch besser
Veganer gekocht
ja
und manchen Menschen gelingt es ja auch
nicht so gut abzuschmecken und zu würzen
und deswegen so kommt man vielleicht
auch so ein bisschen rein in die ganze
Kochkunst
gut das Gemüse darf jetzt ein bisschen
darin garen ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
aufräumen
Salz Pfeffer stelle ich noch mal bereit
Zitrone und Sahne du musst warten Gott
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder wenn
mein Gemüse halb da ist
jetzt gucken wir mal rein
bei der Jutta muss nur noch das Fleisch
gleich dazu bei mir eigentlich auch aber
ich muss auch noch abschmecken schon
fertig bei dir ne
natürlich fehlt Salz
ich habe hier ein frischer Löffel ich
probiere jetzt auch noch bei dir
bei mir die Sahne rein
ihr könnt solche Gerichte auch vegan
zubereiten wenn ihr ein fleischsersatz
nehmt aus Sojas zum Beispiel und einfach
nur pflanzliche pflanzliche Sahne dann
könnt ihr sowas trotzdem lecker
zubereiten ich mache jetzt bei mir noch
ein bisschen
Zitrone rein und was ihr auch machen
könnt die Gemüsebrühe bzw die
Hühnerbrühe auch ein bisschen mit
Weißwein verfeinern dann habt ihr noch
mal so einen intensiveren Geschmack aber
ich finde so jetzt echt gut das heißt
ich glaube ich werde dann auch fertig
bei mir kommt jetzt auch das Fleisch
dazu darf noch ein bisschen ziehen und
dann ist mein Hühnerfrikassee fertig
[Musik]
dann räumen wir jetzt kurz auf und holen
den Murat dazu zum blinzerkosten denn er
weiß gar nicht dass wir gekocht haben
und weiß auch gar nicht was wir hier
gemacht haben
unsere Gerichte sind jetzt fertig
gekocht jetzt hole ich Murat dazu
ja ich war schon lange nicht mehr da ich
weiß aber es sind noch zusammen alles
läuft gut er hat halt so viel zu tun ich
habe keine Affären oder sowas ja er
kümmert sich halt immer um den Garten
und deswegen hat er weniger Zeit für uns
also wir haben jetzt folgendes macht
Murat
zuschauen sehr gewünscht einfache
Gerichte deswegen habe ich die Jutta
weggeschickt und hat dann hat sie
gekauft von Knorr und Magie so
fertiggerichtet und ich habe das jetzt
auf sallysart zubereitet und die Jutta
hat einfach die die
Packung zubereitet ich sagte jetzt nicht
welcher Topf was ist und du darfst blind
verkosten und dein Urteil fällen und ich
weiß also ich finde im Moment man muss
solche Sachen nicht verteufeln manchmal
ein bisschen weniger Zeit dann macht man
das und ich glaube die Zutaten hier drin
sind sind halt sind kann ich nichts
sagen okay aber ist keine Produktion
können machen was ihr wollt ja ich habe
gesagt ich finde sowas grundsätzlich
nicht schlimm und auch nicht schlecht
denn es gibt ja auch Menschen die nicht
gut würzen können und vielleicht auch
die Idee nicht haben und dann oder
vielleicht ist auch einfach günstiger
kann man auch sagen oder ist es auch so
man hat vielleicht weniger Zeit
macht was ihr wollt ohne Spaß also
beides gut
die Zuschauer wissen was was ist weil es
ist nämlich gesehen haben okay ich sag's
nicht okay
ich darf jetzt probieren
nein
ja du darfst auch probieren komm oh ja
Ella ist auch ein guter ein gutes Jury
Mitglied gut geschmeckt muss ich ehrlich
sagen das war wirklich gut
[Musik]
bitte schön Hühnerfrikassee krasse
schmeckt beides identisch
aber ich würde fast sagen dass das etwas
cremiger ist
und ich würde fast also darf ich mal
ehrlich meine ich glaube ich glaube das
ist cremiger und ich glaube das ist auch
nicht das ist nicht das frische von dir
geschmacklich geschmacklich bin ich kein
Unterschied muss ich sagen
du verarschst mich gerade ich weiß
gleiche
ich weiß es war welches dein sich 100%.
das ist deins weil ich das zwar cremiger
ist aber das ist würziger und da ich
mehr Salz drin das weiß es von Dir habe
ich recht
ansonsten wirklich
auch lecker mir fehlt nur bisschen Würze
aber ich weiß dass so Fertiggerichte
tendenziell weniger gewürzt werden weil
zum Beispiel auch Senioren ältere
Menschen oder auch Menschen die nicht so
viel Gewürze wollen dass er so mögen ja
cool ich muss auch sagen ich finde es so
ganz cool tolles Rezept probiert es
gerne mal aus und wenn ihr wach Ella was
eigentlich mit dir wie sieht's aus mit
deiner Bewertung hast du das auch
probiert und das hier auch ist schon
leer ja und ja ich hoffe wir sehen uns
mal wieder öffnen
ich habe jetzt meinen eigenen
YouTube-Kanal und zwar der heißt
raspberry da könnt ihr drauf gehen
raspberry unterzeichnet gartenvideos und
Tipps und Tricks
und
schmeckt's dir muss auch nicht sagen was
besser oder was schlechter schmeckt
Hauptsache dir schmeckts schmeckt gut
aber cool
schreibt gerne falls ihr so einfache
Rezepte
öfter sehen wollt
ja
macht's gut macht es besser
tschüss
Fertiggerichte rein weil dann weiß ich
welches ich dann auch als nächstes
machen kann
echt gut